last month there were rare scenes of
open descent across China protests
flared up in response to lockdown and
restrictions including in the commercial
hub of Shanghai and the capital Beijing
this video behind me was from Shanghai
at the beginning of this month it
resulted in a handbrake turn from the
government which abandoned its covered
zero policies but the protest didn't
come out of nowhere pressure had been
building for months the first one was as
far back as January 2020 or the
beginning of the pandemic when hundreds
of taxi drivers in one Province
protested over a lack of business if you
could see how from Spring 2022 they
really picked up in intensity before
this massive surge now that wasn't just
in Shanghai of course this map shows how
they spread across China the bigger the
dot the larger the protest we haven't
seen any large-scale protests since
China opened up and that's leading to a
different type of online censorship
earlier I spoke to Mania kurtzer who
runs a site called Watson weibo weibo
has its own censorship teams as does
tick tock and many other Chinese social
media apps and
um what exactly the the guidelines are
for censoring of course that varies day
by day and it could actually change hour
by hour now we can't quantify the amount
of censorship but we can see the sort of
posts that are being taken offline
people's messages of support for
protesters and weibo of the Chinese
equivalent of Twitter have been swiftly
deleted but the work that Mania does on
her site preserves deleted posts keep
them online for people to see and this
is a good example we've translated this
person's post and this is what they said
first they're afraid of speech then text
then white papers now even a road sign
they are afraid of everything so why are
we afraid of them let's have a look at
another example this man writes let them
go home it's time to call to release the
protesters thanks to these young men we
can go out of home freely and do not
need to be taken to the cabin hospitals
we're in a new phase now though with
many people happy about the relaxation
of covid 0 and many people worried about
the Omicron wave that are sweeping much
of the country they'll Express that
online and authorities will be keeping a
close eye on both camps